i want you to look at something right
now
thank you some major goal you want or
maybe it's one you're already working on
and you have experienced
a lot of setbacks a lot of defeats
you've experienced a lot of
disappointment maybe you've already
given up
and maybe you just need a little fire a
little encouragement to get back in the
game again
here's what i want you to look at
they're winners
and they're losers and there are people
who have not discovered
how to win and all they need is some
coaching
all they need is some help and
assistance just a little support
all they need is some insight or
different strategy or plan
of action to make some adjustments that
will open up the key to a whole new
future for them
that will give them access to the
unlimited power that they have within
themselves
that's all that they need so what i want
you to do is think about
something you want for you that's real
for you
that's important for you that will give
your life some special meaning and power
and i don't even want you to say i can
do that
i don't want you to assume that see five
years ago when i started out in this
area
i would not have been able to make the
mental leap that i would be up to where
i am right now
i don't want you to begin to just psych
yourself out
no no i want you to be able to say
something to yourself
that will enable you to maintain a level
of integrity with yourself
that when you say this even when you
face tremendous setbacks
it will be a benchmark to keep you in
the game to keep you
moving forward and experimenting and
readjusting your strategy
and your plan of action continuously
looking for ways to win
so what is that something when you got
an idea you want to move on you might
not have the money you might not have
the education
you might not have the support of the
resources you need what is that
something that can keep us going that
will enable us to
act on our dream what's one of those
keys
that will begin to help us to discover
the secrets to our dream
here's what i want you to repeat after
me please with power and conviction say
it's possible
that's all i want you to do when you
look at your dream you say to yourself
every day it's possible you say that
every day to yourself
it's possible because what does that do
see
it begins to change your belief system
see the way in which we operate ladies
and gentlemen
it's a manifestation of what we believe
what's possible for us
whatever you've done up to this point
all that it really is
is a duplication it's a reproduction of
what you believe subconsciously that you
deserve
and what's possible for your life most
people operate out of their personal
history
out of their memory things they've done
things have experienced things they've
seen
things that they have observed what i'm
suggesting that you operate out of a
larger vision of yourself
i want you to see yourself doing what
you want to do experiencing what you
want to experience it
having what you want to have doing what
is
that gives your life some meaning and
value operate out of your imagination
not your memory
because whenever you look at where you
want to go i'm going to warn you
you will have some conversation back
here after you go through the data that
you've experienced in life saying you
can't do it
and so what you want to begin to do is
ignore that inner conversation
well most people ladies and gentlemen
when something happens to them
what they do is they begin to believe
that that's the way it is
that's the way it's always been and they
can't see the possibility
of it being any different example
before in april 1954
the common belief the universal belief
because it had been tried again and
again and again and people have failed
the belief was that man was not
physically capable
of breaking the four-minute barrier that
he could not run a mile
in less than four minutes that was the
belief
on the planet it had never been done
but here's what happened ladies and
gentlemen roger bannister came along
and he broke the four-minute barrier
now here's what's significant about that
since that time
up to this day over 20 000 people have
done it
including high school kids
what changed 20
000 people what changed here's what
happened when they got on the track
they knew it had been done and because
they knew it had been done there was a
new belief
about this barrier about this goal that
was
unreachable and those 20
000 people got in the race believing
knowing in their heart that someone had
done it that it's possible
that they could do it and i'm saying
that if you know anybody that had some
goals some dream
something they wanted to do
and they did it the nice thing that you
know in your heart that if someone
has done it then you can do it it's
possible
and that if someone can make that dream
become a reality that it's
it's possible that you can make your
dream become reality
and so as you begin to look at where you
want to go
beginning to embrace that it's possible
i'm blessed and highly favored i've got
a lot going for me i got some good stuff
in me and it's possible that i can
bring my greatness out here in the
universe that i can do what i want to do
it's possible
i can write my own book i can have my
own business i
i can take the trip and travel around
the world it's possible
i can bounce back from adversity and
reinvent my life
it's possible regardless of where i am
the things
can get better for me it's possible most
people are not
accumulating wealth most people are
living in
poverty most people are living far below
their potential
not because they don't have the capacity
not because they have not
been given authority and dominion over
everything on the face of the earth
but most people are living like they're
living because of the fact that they
don't believe they can have any more
than what they now have
and the book called the miseducation of
the negro dr cotter g woodson said
if you can determine what a man shall
think you'll never have to concern
yourself with what he will do
if you can make a man feel inferior you
never have to compel him to seek an
imperial status
for he will seek it himself and if you
can make a man feel
justly an outcast you never have to
order him to go to the back door
he'll go without being told and if
there's no door
his very nature will demand one
that's why scripture reminds us being
not conformed to this world
but being transformed by the renewing of
your mind
so every day you have to sell yourself
and get out of your mind those old
thoughts that old belief system every
day you've got to sell yourself
on that it's possible that you got to
put a new mind in you you got to get out
of your mind you got to begin to
restructure your thinking
every day you've got to begin to
recondition your mind
see many of us go through life making
choices thinking it's our choices
and it's not i'm saying this is a time
more than ever
that you want to begin to inoculate
yourself
with positive words coming to
conventions
showing up on meetings being on the
calls to make yourself
unstoppable to get out of your mind the
polluting negative
thoughts that's causing most people to
go through life
being stuck because they're volunteer
victims somebody said that many people
die at age 25
and don't get buried until they're 65
because they got so much
garbage in their minds you are here
because you've got a clear vision of
what you want and where you're going
give yourselves a round of applause
come on bring energy level up yes
yes you want more
you want more
you're different
you're different than everybody else
don't worry if they don't get it don't
try and convince people to do this
business
a person convinced against their will is
of the same opinion still
you are not like everybody else you can
walk outside
and find pigeons but if you're looking
for eagles it's going to take you a
minute
you are different it's lonely at the top
how many of you know it's lonely at the
top raise your hands
it's lonely at the top but you eat
better that's what i'm talking about
you're different one great entrepreneur
said i choose not to be a common man
it's my right to be uncommon if i can
i seek opportunity not security i do not
wish to be a kept citizen
humbled and dull by having the state
look after me i want to take the
calculated risk
to dream and to build to fail and to
succeed
i refuse to live from hand to mouth i
prefer the challenges of life
to the guaranteed existence the thrill
of fulfillment to the still calm of
utopia
i will never cower before a master nor
been to any threat
it's my heritage to stand a wreck proud
and unafraid
to face the world boldly and say this i
have done you
showed up because you're building a
business that you can stand and say
i did this i did this
this is my dream give yourselves a round
of applause
yes yes
after having 238 radiation seed implants
i was reading one night some words by dr
howard thurman who was a
mentor to dr martin luther king jr to
albert schweitzer
to mahatma gandhi he wrote deep insta
hunger
the voice of the genuine the centering
moment
as i was reflecting on his words he said
the ideal situation for a man
or woman to die is that family members
praying with them
as they cross over he said but imagine
if you will
being on your death bed and standing
around your bed
the ghost of the dreams the ideas
the abilities the talents given to you
by life but you for whatever reason
you never pursued those dreams you never
acted on those ideas you never used
those gifts
you never used those talents and there
they are staring at you
as you're lying on your bed with large
angry eyes saying we came to you
and only you could have given us life
and now
we must die with you forever
and the question is if you die today
what dreams what talents
[Music]
what abilities what gifts
what ideas would die with you
one minister out of bahama said the
wealth is placed on the planet it's not
in the far east where there's oil on the
ground it's not in south africa where
they're diamond lines it's at the
wealthiest place in the planet is the
cemetery and there you see potential
never realized there you find books
never written
there you find ideas never acted on
maybe that's why
henry david rose said oh god to reach
the point of death
only to realize that you've never lived
only to realize that you've never
scraped the surface of your potential
it's hard changing your life it was hard
when
just over three years ago in the
penobscot building in detroit michigan
where i was operating my business and i
fell on some hard times
and i was sleeping in my office
it was hard coming into the lobby and
the security says excuse me mr brown can
we see you for a moment
and i said yes and i walked up to the
counter and he gave me an envelope
and he said would you mind reading it
here and i opened the envelope
and the envelope was from management
that says this
is an office tower it's not a hotel
please do not sleep in your office
and i said excuse me sir i said i just
worked long hours in creating my
business i'm an entrepreneur
and right now things are bad for me but
they're not going to be
this way always
and i just asked for the opportunity to
continue to operate
like i'm doing i'm not trying to make
this my home
and it was hard coming through the lobby
and sometimes they would laugh there's a
guy talking about becoming successful
and look at him he's bathing in the
bathroom upstairs
on the 21st floor he sleeps on the floor
him and two other dreamers up there look
at him
it was hard ladies and gentlemen coming
to speak to people
and i was facing financial difficulties
in my own life
i was behind on my bills and my dreams
and i'm saying to them
you can live your dream it was hard
ladies and gentlemen
it was very difficult to pick myself up
each day believing
that i could do it there were times that
i doubted myself i said god why
why is this happening to me i'm just
trying to take care of my children
and my mother i'm not trying to steal a
rod from anybody
how did this have to happen to me
it was very hard and here's what i want
to say to you
for those of you that have experienced
some hardships
don't give up on your dream no one could
have convinced me by holding on
by continuing to push forward by
continuing to run toward my dream
that one day i would have my own
talk show it's a long shot ladies and
gentlemen from liberty city an abandoned
building on a floor
never annoying my mother or father it's
a long shot
being here with you today in this dome
in atlanta it's a long shot no college
training labeled educable mentally
[ __ ]
but i kept running toward my dream
don't stop
don't stop
don't stop running towards your dream
i'm thinking about two men right here in
chicago
who are fairly successful
similar background educated
they worked for a corporation for many
years and they were among many people
that were laid off
two guys who were very good friends one
went out looking for a job
for several weeks along with the other
one
and they faced disappointment and
rejection again and again and again
they couldn't find any work which is the
story of many people across this country
one guy stopped he became discouraged
he stopped going he stayed home looking
at television
became very argumentative and toxic with
his wife
drinking beer getting on the phone
talking to his other negative
unemployed friends
and he just gave up the other guy kept
looking for a job everywhere he could go
every time he could get an opportunity
kept asking people
networking checking the newspapers every
day kept going
everywhere he could trying to find a job
you have too much education you're
overqualified you won't be here long
enough
he kept going he kept going he went to a
place and said look here i tell you what
if you can't hire me
and i know you can use my talents
abilities and skills
i don't want to sit home and do nothing
just just let me do some volunteer work
you don't have to give me anything all
right
i just want to work i want to be busy
guy said okay it's on you now but don't
don't expect me to give you anything
it's okay
this guy came in and worked he was the
first one there
the last one to leave was the best
employee there
about four weeks later one of the top
managers quit they were looking for a
replacement guess who they selected
this other guy this guy who was
volunteering his time
he got the job what was the difference
between the two men
eyesight and mind sight eyesight is
judging on what you see
judging according to appearances but
mindsight is how you interpret what you
see
one guy said it's not possible it's over
i'm finished
i can't do it i can't make it
he's surrendered i've faced rejection
again and again i'm not going anymore
there are no jobs
out there but this other guy
he felt that in spite of the no's and
rejections in spite of how bad the
economy is
in spite of what the newspapers are
saying
that it's possible that somebody
somewhere
will give me a job he just kept going
thinking it was possible and guess what
ladies and gentlemen
that's what we have to do with our
dreams because things
happen to you in life that you can never
ever
anticipate and many times when those
things happen
you want to give up i remember when i
was in broadcasting when i was a disc
jockey i became very controversial
not only being a disc jockey but i felt
that radio was something that
you not only entertain people with but
you also empower them you educate them
and i got fired i didn't just leave they
fired me
that was a shock
i said wait a minute they took my
microphone
i thought that was who i was
no no ladies and gentlemen it wasn't i
had to do
something else and i didn't know what
else i could do
see here's what i'm looking at what are
the uses for your life right now that
you haven't even
reached for yet see i believe that when
you don't have enough encouragement to
act on your dreams or ideas
or you're not enlightened enough that
life will
act on you see life has moved on me and
said les brown you have outgrown this
it's time for you to do something else
well i wasn't enlightened enough i
organized some disc jockeys and got my
job back
if you want some wayne dyer affirmations
for success check out the video right
there next to me i think you'll enjoy it
continue to believe and i'll see you
there if i want to give you
a dozen oranges i can't give you those
dozen oranges
unless i go out and pick up 12 oranges
someplace